I remember when people at Miramax came
to us and said could you make it PG-13
there's no violence or sex to speak of
you know it it's just and I said what's
keep what's making it rated R and they
said the language what the [ __ ] are you
talking about and I said okay well so we
could Loop a couple lines and they go
yeah but you're only allowed I think at
the time it was allowed you were allowed
to say the f word three times and all
your money on these [ __ ] fancy books
you surround yourselves with them
they're the wrong [ __ ] books one of
the right [ __ ] books well and I said
okay well how many are we off by and
they said you go over by 145. what the
[ __ ] is the point that you start and I I
think being from Boston I don't think we
realized how much we swore and and and I
don't swear that much anymore and so you
say that instead of uh it was it was
literally a placeholder like you go
oh I know what I wanted to tell you you
know and it just and so we wrote it the
way we you know when Ben and I wrote it
we would we would do the lines together
and yeah okay and then we transcribe it
you
said you know right and and so so no I
haven't shown the kids that one